hey everybody it's Mike from order flows
and it's uh you know it's Monday
September 26th and you know last night
Sunday night British pound had a big
sell-off right we dropped from about uh
you know the 108 area down to you know
104. that was a pretty massive and sharp
drop that happened pretty quick and what
I want to talk about today is you know
was there anything in the order flow
that you could have seen that would have
keyed you in on the move you know and to
be honest this move it was very dramatic
it was a very big move and
most likely you know if you got short up
here around the 108 ish area yeah you
would have to take profit and maybe you
got you know you're covered at 107 and a
half or 107 even yeah you're not gonna
to say yeah you know I would have sold
it up here and covered it down here at
105. no I mean you know I always
recommend Traders have a
use an ATM right you have a stop and you
have a take profit and most likely this
move happens so fast your take profit
would have been hit even if you moved it
you would have maybe backed it off an
extra 10 or 15 ticks you're not going to
drop it all the way down to you know to
106 or 105 even you know be realistic so
all those Traders are saying yeah you
know you could have made through two 300
Pips out of this move no you know your
take profit would have been hit because
this move was was pretty quick and
you would have just been happy with your
take profit okay and just put this move
into perspective
um you know a couple weeks ago I don't
know if I have it on this chart let me
uh adjust the
data on here
change that to two weeks so I think it
was around the the
middle of the month around the 13th or
14th where was we had another
we had a big drop
uh where are we here 13 yeah here okay
and you know this is a move from
basically 117.50
down to you know 116 even it was right
down here you know we got as low as you
know 115.61 and this was a very sharp
drop it was you know you're talking 200
ticks you know but the move last night
was double that actually uh where are we
here
you know again sort of starting up in
here around the 108 even but let's take
it from this break here at 107.50 107.50
to 104 this is 104.50 did get down to
104. but 104.50 107.50 300.
Tech so it was quite a dramatic move and
just sort of put down what's happened in
perspective on the daily chart I mean
this pound has been uh has been dropping
all year long I mean just going back to
you know the beginning of the year is
right here are sort of our high in back
in January is you know 1 37 you know 45
basically now look at this we're trading
all the way down here pretty soon we're
gonna hit parity right I think uh
they're gonna stop calling
football we're gonna call it soccer now
um that's how uh weak the pound has been
but let's take a look at the order flow
okay because there are some interesting
things in the order flow that were uh
Brewing so to speak and
here's the footprint chart
so this is where you know so Sunday
night again you know demonstrators
aren't trading Forex on Sunday night you
know this is happening at you know sort
of the beginning of the Asian session so
right now what markets are open
Australia well New Zealand's going to be
the first major I wouldn't call it New
Zealand a major financial center but
it's you know on the Sunday on the
reopens that's the first Market that
opens New Zealand I mean they do trade
you know bank bills and stuff over there
but um you know don't by any it's not a
major Financial Center
um Australia will open up a little bit
later and then Japan will open up okay
when I say Japan you know there's this
weird Japan's in Asia but there's like
uh you know these Asian desks you know
they have a Japan desk you know so it's
X Japan I mean everything else yeah
China Hong Kong Thailand Singapore it's
all lumped together except for Japan
um but anyway so Sunday night again most
Traders aren't really looking at what's
happening in the currencies when they
reopen unless they're really die-hard
Traders so you know we reopened at you
know around the 108
where am I hearing on this Friday
here it is you know pretty much open
unchanged
from Friday's session okay and you know
we're trading around the other 108.50
area and it's just sort of humming along
we got this first initial push down
about 640 but again nothing to get too
excited about
um then we're starting to see
stuff brewing in the order flow here
right I got a bearish pound opponent
control I got stopping volume coming in
108 22 area
now
again Sunday nights
six seven o'clock volumes are light okay
bear that in mind so even though volumes
are light you know we're seeing 106 283
128 normally you're going to see you
know anything over 100 would be
considered very big but you're seeing
basically between 50 and 100 but you're
seeing some Deltas in here right you're
getting these big stretches of negative
Delta over one two three four five six
seven eight nine bars okay and the
market starts coming down to our low of
the day here at 107.95 this was the low
that we made earlier
now as we're coming down you can see in
here let me just uh make this chart a
little bit bigger
we've got one two three four five six
pointed controls
out of eight bars at the same level
okay you got
um two bearish Prime Quarter controls
you got a bullish palm and point of
control here but Mark is not going
anywhere we're sort of rotating around
this 108 10 area
and you know you do string together a
little bit of positive Deltas but small
2 28 16 negative eight plus fifty one
negative four negative nine nothing to
get excited about and it sort of came on
the back of all this negative Delta in
here now remember right we had that
bearish Prominent Point of control here
we got two bearish pound opponent
controls appearing here so we've got
three bearish Mount reported controls
what our imbalance is doing well here
you've got one two three four five
imbalances in this bar that's got eight
price levels so predominantly all
selling imbalances
two cylinder balances here one here
three here
one here one here
one two three four in this bar as we're
coming down into the lows now as we're
coming down into these lows what do we
see in the Delta well Delta is picking
up volume sort of picking up and when
you've got 123 here but what was
interesting is you got minus 24 Delta
then minus 32 minus 93. this is what I
call the Delta search and you know I
actually have a free indicator for this
on my website that just highlights where
you have increasing Delta like this from
positive to negative to more negative to
even more negative and a bullish one
would be the opposite
because what's happening is sellers more
and more sellers are coming into the
market and taking control of that market
now
you still need to follow through order
flow right you do want to see the market
start to sell off afterwards and you
start to see it in here now ideally I'd
like to see a bearish Delta surge you
know somewhere a little bit higher not
necessarily going into the low but you
can only trade what the market gives you
if it's giving it to you going into the
low just be careful because we know that
now you can look back and say oh yeah
that was so obvious but you know
oftentimes you look at
you get the increase in Delta going into
lows and then it makes a new low by five
ten ticks and then it reverses and
starts rallying okay I mean I'd rather
get short from a higher level than at
the lows of the day but again you know
on a market that's trending
you want to get short at the lows okay
if it's trending down obviously you want
to get short at the lows so that was a
couple of things there right you've seen
the bearish power controls right the
point of control on this extreme
indicating stopping volume
um you've got six point of controls
lined up here so you know the market is
forming a balance and ideally what you
want to see is the market start to break
out of balance and what direction it's
going we know it's going down we got
more sound and balances coming in seeing
the sellers get stronger here
in terms of Delta negative 24 negative
32 and negative 93 and you know this is
something that I one of the early
forms of analysis I did on Delta was
many years ago when I used to trade palm
oil and it'd be very boring markets it'd
just be like this from here to here
right and I would just look for where
buyers or sellers are starting to come
in before the markets move and that's
how I saw what a Delta surge was you
know I I don't say I invented it but I'm
the one that coined the term I was the
only one using it for many years and
it's available again you know it's free
on my website if you use ninjatrader8
and again you know it's a nice thing to
look for but you still need to confirm
it with the Delta so obviously the
market started selling off okay 108 we
broke you know 107.95
started coming down Boom Big Bar down
finally we got the break from 107 79
down to 54. okay then what happens we go
inside
inside inside of this bar
so we got one two three four bars and
when you start going inside of a bar
then you gotta start looking for more
breakouts either to the downside or to
the upside of this bar that everything's
inside
because once it's got that big push down
the big wide ranging bar then the next
bar goes inside you I know that
generally you're going to see the market
sort of rotate around it's going to go
sideways and then I gotta look for the
next breakout and then it comes down
here so all you got to do take advantage
of this is you just put a sell stop down
here around 53 at the new lows or you
put a buy stop up here at 80 in case it
sort of starts rallying back up and
recovering everything and then finally
it breaks through again now look at this
okay so earlier I'm not going to show
you where price was
you have this period from 720 to 7 28.
all negative Delta then you get this
period from 736 to
741 all negative Delta get the one
positive here but then again from 743
you know all the way here to
751 all negative Delta so sellers
obviously in control right it bounces
again
here doesn't build on it doesn't get out
of this high or this low
all you gotta do is just bracket it okay
are we going to bounce back up above 37
are we going to break below 15. as
you're coming down into the low you got
a nice aggressive selling in here you
got a nice stacked imbalances five
levels deep 545 37 24 42.
and the market again
wide ranging bar down
right again it's a it's a move from 107
22 down to 106.82 that's a wide ranging
bar right it's covering a lot of ground
it's covering what is that about 40
ticks okay then the next bar goes inside
next bar goes inside okay I'm expecting
this Market to go sideways just as it
had over the last two drops so I'm just
going to put a buy stop up there around
23 so I'll stop around 80. next bar
later boom it just breaks 80 and that's
it it's just no looking back
I mean just keeps dropping and dropping
and dropping so
and again you could look at the Delta
again you got another Delta surge
growing in here it's positive 48 minus
34 minus 73 minus 111 you know that's
when it was still trading way up in here
right
here here here
this bar so again all you got to do is
just get ready to be shorting it around
you know 15 new lows 10 5 whatever 107
even even
and finally you get that big breaking
bar here where stops just get triggered
and it's just Look Out Below and we just
drop in that one minute from
um what was that 106.
91 down to 105 I think 86 oh 82 here
so you know a nice 100 Point move in one
bar
okay but again you wouldn't have
most likely you wouldn't have caught all
100 ticks because you'd place your order
to get in then your ATM is going to kick
off you know maybe you got a 25 tick
take profit 30 tick take profit and it's
going to get filled
you know within a few seconds so you're
happy you made your profit you know you
don't kick yourself like oh I got short
at 106.75 and I only covered it at uh at
40 when I could have covered it down
here at 105.80 no you know you start
messing around with your take profits
and stuff like that you end up screwing
yourself
so anyway guys
um you know that was what was
interesting on this move and down in the
British pound you know it's funny
because British pound has uh recovered a
lot of it already today just uh go back
to the let's go back to the five minute
chart so this was that move down but you
can see we rallied back above we made
new highs actually of the day up here at
109 31 we're sort of sound a little bit
at you know this 106 85-ish area so
we're going sideways in here
but um yeah I mean there was some
bearish things happening in the order
flow before that big drop so
anyway guys I hope you appreciate this
video be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already you know I'm trying to put out
videos on a fairly consistent basis now
so enjoy and happy trading bye bye